and now last week tonight asks how is
this still a thing this week voting on
Tuesday how is this still a thing in the
United States two things are for certain
first elections for national office are
held on the first Tuesday after the
first Monday in November and second
every time it happens we're going to ask
why is that when this question first
came up here none of us knew why it is
we vote on Tuesdays have you ever
wondered why we vote on Tuesdays
everyone knows Election Day is always
Tuesday but we wondered why and it's not
just newscasters nobody seems to know I
do not know why elections are held on
Tuesday on a Tuesday I'm not sure
actually I don't think it's question do
you know I feel like I should but no no
yes even human pickles don't know why we
vote on Tuesday it's just one of those
mysteries that no one can figure out
like where's the remote or why doesn't
Jason Bourne just Google himself but the
reason actually comes from the 1845 law
passed for a very 1845 reason people had
very limited access to move about
polling stations or where they'd vote
would be extreme distances they had to
find a way of making election day some a
day that people could could accommodate
their schedules weekends were no good
because of the Sabbath so take Monday as
a travel day and voila vote on Tuesdays
yes we vote on Tuesdays because of the
Sabbath making voting day the only thing
in American life still scheduled around
Sundays other than the operating hours
of chick-fil-a and new episodes of
America's Funniest Home Videos oh that's
right that thing's still
on and it will be on long after this
nonsense is canceled
and one states allowed early voting or
mail-in voting thirteen states don't and
the problem is having everyone voted
once on a Tuesday can cause scenes like
this here in the valley
I voted turnout for election day this is
video from the Oakwood University
precinct where voters waited for upwards
of three hours at times today to cast
their ballots the lines have been long
at polls all across central Mississippi
tonight people waited for hours to cast
their ballots in the cold and the rain
hearing is flatbush the line to vote
stretch through the hall and up the
stairs but wait there's more this whole
auditorium of people is the line to get
on the line holy all the way times
of Disney World all the fun of the
DMV and for some the fact voting
takes place on a workday is a major
inconvenience on Tuesday I have to work
in them an hourly employee so anytime
taking away from work is just I just I
have to wake up earlier exactly perhaps
that's why the most common reason
Americans give for not voting is that
they were too busy which even means too
busy working although it could mean too
busy coming up with sick cool dogs like
this one
because this is America and there is all
sorts of really cool to do
so what could be done well we could
expand early voting move election day to
a weekend or keep it where it is and
declare it a national holiday like it is
important Co where their turnout is not
only consistently higher than the 50
states but their voting day is
consistently more awesome
but until we do that we're going to be
forced to squeeze in voting in between
work doctor's appointments or a few
quick REM rattling nerf dogs just so
farmers who have been dead for more than
a century won't have an excuse to miss
church all of which returns us to the
question voting on Tuesday how is this
still a thing
[Applause]
you